what should non-asians know about being
asian in the uh or simple but how could
they not
you know someone like me how can i not
be a dick or is there something and i've
never asked this before but it's
something that you wish
folks of other races or maybe just white
people knew about being asian that isn't
talked about or you've never said or
others haven't said i think that the the
main thing that most asian americans
would want were just to be regarded as
three-dimensional
human beings with uh
thoughts feelings hopes ambitions
uh sense of humor etc etc and not to be
reduced to any trade including race i
think that's what most people want yeah
and i my favorite quote from you on the
presidential when someone had said well
you are
repurposing and promoting a stereotype
when you use a math slogan or things
like that and you said maybe
but you know it's also not the asian
american stereotype is standing next to
joe biden and running for president
right yeah like the entire thing it's
like you're reinforcing asian
stereotypes it's like are you
kidding me like i'm running for
president it's like the least asian
thing you can do
so shut the up is what i'd wanted
to say but of course you know you can't
say that stuff when you're running props
you have to be like oh i understand
people can take a joke but internally i
was like like look a round you
it's like what am i doing here you know
[Music]
this week on board i follow up my
interview with jay caspian kang about
asian american identity and politics
what is going on with that cnn piece
about kamala harris beto o'rourke
running for governor
where are american leaders what is going
on with the bench and much much more
this week
hey everyone it's great to be back with
you i had a blast this week on the
podcast with jay caspian kang author of
the loneliest americans which is now
here on on the bookshelf
if you haven't listened to that convo do
check it out
i found it edifying a little bit
cathartic
it was fun talking to someone who was
making a bunch of arguments about the
asian american community that i thought
were very
courageous very original very honest and
it wasn't me
that's fair you've been asked to
talk about your identity more often than
you've always wanted to i feel like the
people forcing you to make your races
about your identity when you are trying
to run on issues yeah it's certainly
part of the media today and it was
fascinating the treatment of
the presidential campaign where you
remember when i was like the last
candidate uh who wasn't white on the
debate stage in california in the sixth
debate i think
and
one of the jokes i told internally was
like we're about to find out if asians
are white
because
in terms of whether
the media would make a thing out of it
uh and this is after kamala drop down
we're going to talk about kama a little
later this after cory had dropped out
this is after a lot of people had
dropped out
so
certainly the media i will say has like
a selective treatment of race where like
they'll be obsessed about it if it
reinforces certain narratives that
they're really into augmenting and then
they'll completely mute it
if it if it
fits into a narrative they don't like uh
and i will say that my presidential
campaign seemed to fall into the latter
category because asian americans in
politics is not a super mainstream
topic
and i want to go into a few of the facts
around it because i think it'll be
interesting to at least some people so
maybe surprising to folks or maybe
completely unsurprising but asian
americans are the most underrepresented
community in the country in terms of
electoral politics we're about six
percent of the population let's say and
that doesn't show up in terms of
elected representatives
and there are a number of structural
reasons for that one
we don't run for offices often we don't
vote as often we don't donate as often
so that's clearly just you know facts
and you know that's something that i'd
like to change i mean if there's a
community that's not as politically
engaged though i share all the time that
when i grew up my parents did not talk
about politics at all and i have a
feeling a lot of asian-american
households are the same and so i think
that there's a lot of
conditioning that one needs to try to
make a break from
but there are structural reasons around
why we're not as
often represented another is that we
tend to be in very blue or red areas
where we're not really that important a
population um in a lot of contexts and i
had a joke all the time which is if we
all moved to new hampshire
or some place that's really like
politically
you know
important but if we're wedged into
larger populations in
new york or texas or california though i
will also say that california is maybe
the biggest uh
different type of environment where you
do have asian american elected officials
mayors et cetera now there's a mayor in
boston for the first time um so
congratulations to michelle wu so but
by and large that there is like a
pattern around asian american political
engagement and representation that's
kind of low
and when i was growing up
one another reason for this was that
asian americans were kind of split along
party lines there was a slight
democratic lien but it was something
like 55-45 there were a lot of
asian-american republicans because
they're small business owners they voted
on one issue which was taxes
and that has changed recently somewhat
in part because of trump and the china
virus and all of that like the
republicans have taken on this sort of
nativist feeling that a that asian
americans sense it may not include them
um though i'd also suggest that the
predominant democratic party narrative
of elevating
oppressed people of color also doesn't
really include asian americans and we've
seen that
in different ways
so
to the point of jay's book i think asian
americans are somewhat politically
homeless truly uh and um i think the
democratic party
is presenting a case that look you have
no choice but to vote for us because
look at the other side i mean you have
trump uh literally stoking xenophobia in
the rest of it and over the last number
of years there has been a real movement
in that direction where asian americans
now vote democratic
something like 60 40 or 65 30 35. okay
it was almost two to one democratic in
georgia for example yep uh and so there
there is this sense that uh asian
americans are trending
democratic um at the same time though i
do think that the democratic party has
not really emphasized the asian-american
community and the asian american
community officials i've talked to
silently echo that uh in in different
ways
and i think there's also a dynamic where
democrats like well you don't have a
choice but to vote for us because you're
not white and look at the other side um
but when it comes to actually
emphasizing issues that affect asian
americans
like at least i'll say for myself like i
don't really see it coming from either
side but the democratic party i think
makes a stronger claim and then doesn't
necessarily follow through
couple questions for you on this um
what you're talking about is both
parties in some ways inability to drum
up
the fight drum up the support
collectively amongst the asian
population
and there's a number of reasons my
question to you is
do you think the pitch to an asian
american in the united states of america
to get involved in politics is very high
um like what's the roi
to get into the fight for the asian
community and what i mean is like
is it because representation is some is
an argument that's made in various
communities and that doesn't always
solve the problem i think um
it's not like a
money-making path like a lot of
asian-americans i find are doing their
thing and don't tend to care they're
apolitical or don't care about politics
and i don't know what what are your
thoughts on the roi or the actual pitch
for either party to get him involved
well first let me say also that jay's
argument in his book is that asian
american identity is not really a thing
i didn't read the book you did that it's
so it's an academic construction uh it
was created at berkeley in the aftermath
of the civil rights movement of the 60s
i went to college and joined
a college student organization that had
asian american in the name so i i'm of
the population that jay's describing
that gets socialized into this
asian-american identity but the majority
of immigrant communities who come here
uh aren't socialized in that way uh he
uses his parents as an example so the
first issue is that the asian american
community
may not be a thing
[Laughter]
like when you say that like help me
understand like coming out outside of
that community like when you say not a
thing you mean they they like they're
not
identifying as asian in that sense that
shared community of asian-ness in your
way or that's part of it yes okay
so one part of it is that they'd be more
likely to identify with their nation of
origin okay so they'd be more likely to
identify as laotian
or korean um well before they would
consider themselves asian-american
that's interesting okay so that's number
one is there's a nationalistic identity
the second thing is that the community
is the most diverse of any community in
terms of both education level and
socioeconomic background
the point you're making is
what is the rational thing and a lot of
immigrant communities who show up here
don't give a about politics because
they're just like i'm just here to try
and make a decent life for my family
politics is kind of a luxury sport
you know what i mean like like you you
get to you have to have a certain degree
of confidence
or or time or bandwidth um in order to
get engaged and my parents did not give
a about politics because they were
just here just grinding trying to make a
living
and that goes double or triple for newer
communities who come here and may not
have uh educational
opportunities may not have language and
so they're they get here they have kids
uh and they're like hey figure it out
but uh it's not like um like they're not
super concerned or stressed about
politics and then if you go and try and
activate them which by the way i think
is a worthy endeavor i mean i'm for it
um so so there are there are a number of
things that make this asian-american
identity somewhat elusive i think jay's
point is that it's kind of an invented
media fiction um in part because
they want a language or term to be able
to talk about this community in which
makes sense uh and the quote from his
book that i love so much is like we know
we don't have it as bad as you
which is uh referring to black people
but we're not white and we need a way to
talk about it
and so there's this group of educated
college-educated asian americans who've
been using this term as a political
media construction one of jay's
arguments that the people who are quote
unquote professional asian americans
don't actually speak for these immigrant
communities in large part because they
have not much in common with them so
there's something of this fractious
community
a lot of which is totally disengaged but
you know i would contrast it with
someone like igenpoo who's uh an
asian-american labor activist who
definitely is working in immigrant
communities i mean like
like she
and she's working with
uh domestics who are uh latino and like
different backgrounds so like that that
form of activist does exist
but jay's point is that when you talk
about politics or media then there's
like only a certain layer
of uh asian americans who will care a
lot about that maybe those who are
brought up here and are have more
heavily invested in a sense of
uh feeling like we're full-fledged
americans right
and this is something you know i
certainly and i have a lot in common
with jay in terms of our backgrounds uh
so i i get them both it's like i get
there are a number of points here one is
that asian american is uh it may not be
and one of the things i talked about all
the time when the media asked me about
this is be like hey what do you think
about your you know math jokes or blah
blah blah it says about asian american
computer i'm just like look
i would never even pretend to speak for
an entire giant community of millions of
people that i know
you know like russell gibbet so
you know but but at the same time
there's like this sense that i know i'm
one of the more visible
uh public figures in the asian american
community and so like there is a certain
you know level of
um
responsibility not to you know be
terrible
i suppose which by the way you know i
obviously think that you know people
understand
uh jokes and humor or like me relating
my personal experience and not
pretending it speaks for everybody
um
so the the calculation around trying to
get asian americans more politically
engaged to me is like look we have to
try and become more a part of
american politics because it's going to
affect us the the problem right now is
that
and this is jay's argument as well as
that race in america is very much a
black white construction and you can see
this again with and i'm just going to
project out with like latinos like which
is a similar dynamic where latino i mean
and it's like very diverse a lot of
people just trying to make things happen
for themselves and their families and
you stick a mic in their face and be
like what do you think about
you know this is that they'll be like
you know and it's something that
i saw play on the presidential trail for
sure i think that those two
immigrant communities have some
commonalities or you know common frankly
some common uh issues around political
engagement
[Music]
we all do it
we all
take number twos and then the question
is what happens after around the world
when you need to wipe you actually don't
wipe you use water you use something
called a bidet here in the u.s we're a
little bit behind the curve on a number
of things and one of them is the way we
take care of the basics if you order
tushy
it's like a bidet that connects to your
everyday household toilet it's cleaner
it's better for the environment it's
more effective it's modern it's european
it's asian it's sustainable it really is
like an upgrade
it's one reason why i'm very happy to be
sponsored by tushy give the gift of
cleanliness to yourself your loved ones
this holiday season and get 10 percent
off plus free shipping right now at
hellotushi.com yang you can tag them at
hellotushi on social media so they can
help celebrate that's
hellotushi.com
yang for 10 off and free shipping
cleaner more environmentally friendly
no you can't go wrong
[Music]
you just did a show in new york last
saturday which was great sold out this
is fun um
you talked about on the show and i've
heard you talk about before
your invisibility cloak as an asian man
um where like if i wanted to be
anonymous or hidden you felt that you
could do it oh yeah just
don't
uh stick your face into someone else's
face and you you know you could just
walk by
[Laughter]
do you
i'm curious at how that or one you can
one love you to like unpack that further
but also if it's tied to or can it be is
it tied to
this concept of otherness that i feel
like the asian american community lives
with um where you're not and you got it
some a bit i think we ran for mayor
where you're not really a new yorker
even though you've been here for 25
years yeah uh
and anything you did that wasn't
i don't know like traditional new yorker
you said your favorite subway station
was times square which is by the way
where you live and if you listen that
full quote you're like yeah it's my
favorite one because it's the one i take
all the time um
like oh he's a tourist you had political
cartoons that were in my opinion
offensive and um
little backlash from those who usually
call out those sort of things as
offensive um like
does that visibility cloak you're
talking about play into the otherness of
the asian american community am i
overthinking that i don't know what you
think well one of the things that jay
and i talked about which i found
hysterical uh where he said uh
on the podcast he was like people just
don't give a about the internal
lives of asian americans
which i laughed at because i thought
well it's pretty true and then he talked
about the tension of writing a book
around something that people don't give
a about
so i think that's the way that
um you adapt
over time
uh and i would say that people there's
like a spectrum of racism where it's
like you know that anti-black racism is
much more serious and destructive uh and
so then if you complain about racism
towards like another group and
everyone's like yeah you know
that's part of yeah that's part of jay's
point
um
and so
certainly that otherness
and
let me say that
i feel very american uh i got into some
trouble because you know i wrote
something that frankly assumed asian
americans were americans
and i got to trouble with you know with
people who um who somehow imagined that
i was calling our americans into
question when i was really assuming it
yeah uh
i love this country i mean my parents
immigrated here and i think um you know
at the same time like i don't have any
illusions about the fact that
um that people
perceive
who i am at least partially as an asian
guy and you know there are certain um
things that come with that and uh you
know as like a an adult
like there are some things that i i took
for granted including this invisibility
cloak i was joking about but it turns
out that i was completely wrong about
the invisibility cloak because now when
i walk the streets of new york or
anyplace else people are like yang
you're no longer invisible yeah where's
my thousand bucks and i'm like oh you
know like
oh that's that's different but i'd say
it's positive different and i'm trying
to make the most of this i do want to
activate asian americans that are
uh right now disengaged in some of these
issues and i'm really happy to say that
my campaign did that like i met a lot of
people from different communities uh who
said
uh look you know you may be interested
in politics in politics you made me care
and i think that's a good thing you know
i think that assuming that degree of
involvement is like a sign of confidence
and maturation
which i love
though i will also say that if someone
decides that politics is just anxiety
producing and depressing and they want
to ignore it for uh an extended period
of time i'm with you there too it's like
you know like don't worry about it you
know it's like you you
yeah
because of
a lot of the things you know like
frankly the media trump beat um which
we're gonna we're gonna talk about
uh the recent article about kamala but
like the the media uh is definitely race
obsessed in a way that i certainly think
most asian americans are not like most
asian americans
in my experience are just trying to make
good things happen for themselves and
their family uh and
yeah like that and if there are media
products that they want to consume that
have a lot of asian faces there are a
lot of those products that are being
made in people's native countries you
know like a lot of the koreans i know
just watch korean dramas and
like perfectly happy that said also i am
of that group of people that loves it
when
uh creators and artists of um different
communities like are trying to make that
happen in part because it's so hard so
like i do support asian american
uh writers and artists and the rest of
it because i feel
the
that's a resistance that's a good segue
in this last question i asked you so i
think
it's not i don't i think by that we've
looked at some numbers so we could pull
them up if we want to dive in further
but yours your point that most asian
americans you think are not race
obsessed i think most americans are not
race obsessed and i know that people
have told me that's a
uh or you know the classic white guy
saying i don't see racism is a place of
privilege and i agree with that but i
also you could also be true to the other
extent that not it's still not everybody
thinking racism all the time or seeing
race and only race but my my question is
you know at least from my own personal
experience as i was a straight white guy
my whole thing is i'm trying to be an
ally trying not to be an like on
most days um
and
my question is what
what should non-asians know about being
asian in the uh or simple but how could
they not
you know someone like me how can i not
be a dick or is there something and i've
never asked this before but it's
something that you wish
folks of other races or maybe just white
people knew about being asian that isn't
talked about or you've never said or
others haven't said
well you and i've worked together for
years so clearly
i've got a lot of this through osmosis i
think and i've lived the community many
ways oh i you know i think that the the
main thing that most asian americans
would want were just to be regarded as
three-dimensional
human beings with
thoughts feelings hopes ambitions
uh sense of humor etc etc and not to be
reduced to any trade including race i
think that's what most people want yeah
and i my favorite quote from you on the
presidential when someone had said well
you are
repurposing and promoting a stereotype
when you use a math slogan or things
like that and you said maybe
but you know it's also not the
asian-american stereotype is standing
next to joe biden and running for
president right yeah like the entire
thing is like you're reinforcing asian
stereotypes it's like are you
kidding me like i'm running for
president it's like the least asian
thing you can do
so shut the up is what i'd wanted
to say but of course you know you can't
say that stuff when you're running for
obviously you have to be like oh i
understand people can take a joke but
internally i was like like look a
round you it's like what am i
doing here you know
and i will say too that like this is one
of the things that irritate irritated
the out of me it's like you find
like seven
irritating but you know asian americans
with like organizations that barely
exist and be like oh look we found these
asian americans to say like andrew yen
doesn't speak for us it's like one i
would never pretend to speak for
everyone in the community but two it's
like do something
you know what i mean
you know but then the fact that the
media like would like to like to beat
that you know why because
it serves the media's narrative and you
know who it doesn't serve like everyone
else
like the american public all of us you
know it is like people who want good
things to happen asian america like that
does not help but you know like
that there's like this yeah it's like a
device you know it and it's something
it's happening to jay too by the way and
so you know like at the end of my
conversation with jay we we had a moment
about
that
yeah so i'll i'll drop that i love well
it's it's we we live this world where a
lot of people are pretending to or
claiming to be
championing progress or usually the
blockade uh to that progress well they
have just a very very narrow definition
and and it's around
social media and things that
don't matter to the vast majority of
people um and so then you know you just
like get caught up in that and then like
that like that's the coin to the realm
it's one of the diseases of this time
oh it's where we live every day brother
that's why i mean look and we appreciate
all of you for listening it's one of
it's a place where you can actually have
a conversation on this that isn't
it's gray not black and white most
things are
maybe that could be jay's book
title instead of the loneliest americans
not black or white
[Music]
people think i'm a very very upbeat guy
which i appreciate a great deal but we
all struggle we all get down in the
dumps and when you are down and facing
some issues that you want to talk to
someone about the fact is your friends
and family don't really want to hear
about your stuff
they'll hear about it once
and then after that i'll be like oh you
know
get someone else which
is why better help is so important
better help is on-demand professional
therapy whenever you need it you reach
out it's totally confidential and
professional and affordable
we swear by our sponsor better help
carry it forward because it actually
lives up to its name it's better help
than your friends and family because
they actually
want to help you and listen to what
you're going through
i want you we all want to start living a
better happier life as a listener you'll
get 10 off your first month by visiting
our sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang join over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health you
can do it again that's
betterhelphelp.comyang you'll be glad
you did and your loved ones will be glad
too
[Music]
all right let's talk about kamala harris
because
i must summarize this i want to get your
thoughts so kamala harris who
i would say behind the scenes is a
friend i always like to interact with
her you and her really friendly on the
trail like friends there's probably too
much of a stretch and that you're not
spending a ton well it's politics but i
uh get along well
spend some time yeah like but you know
in presidential candidates
uh we wind up spending time with each
other on the trail like i spoke directly
before or after kamala
at least half a dozen maybe a dozen
times uh you know we'd like hang out in
the airport for half an hour sometimes
like you know things like that would
happen on the trail yeah who and then a
lot of these things like especially the
way our two-part system works like who
they are as a person and how they
publicly personify themselves they can
be different like we always like to hang
out with with and her team in the
debates and at the airport and things
like that
so
cnn um comes out with a piece
exasperation and dysfunction inside
kamala harris's frustrating start as
vice president
and it's cnn it's our friend the friend
of the show is edward isaac dover um
we like i think he's a pretty journalist
um
and
basically i'm gonna thought about this
quick summary is that uh the belief is
that she's been so she's being sidelined
and constrained
within the abaddon administration and
the direct quote is that harris's staff
has repeatedly failed her and left her
exposed and family members have often
had informal say within her office even
some who have been asked for advice
lament harris's overly cautious
tendencies and staff problems which have
been a feature of every office she's
ever held from san francisco district
attorney to u.s senate that's kind of
the opening paragraph um and it goes on
with a lot of crap about the kamala
harris experience in the white house
right now so
andrew i love your general thoughts on
this as someone who's had like process
stories come out on you i would like i
think what we can offer here is like how
to sort through the grains of truth in
here and the media hype around it and
general political so general
thoughts and then we can dive in
specifically so my reaction was holy cow
someone has it in for kamala
what was the reaction
uh it's
uh a story that gets generated when a
few people want this story out there in
the world
and so it makes you think who wants the
story out in the world
now are there some elements of truth
almost certainly yes could you write the
story about you know a whole range of
political figures because you know
there's going to be some uh dysfunction
or adjustment or whatever also yes
but kamala
has been subject to a number of these
types of stories this might be the most
prominent because it's on cnn which
generally is very very you don't see a
lot of this type of like
they when they do investigative stuff
they usually take a long time to do it
and it's like a moral ordeal you know
what i'm saying i agree this was so that
this seemed very very significant
because it was cnn and cnn is as
mainstream as you get
and generally very very buttoned up and
responsible isaac is very buttoned up
and responsible this thing is well
sourced
um so a number of things that i think
are going on big picture
the democrats right now are definitely
trying to figure out what the line of
succession looks like which is not
necessarily what you want given that
right now joe's kind of challenged um so
joe's got a 43 percent approval rating
last i checked um they're looking for
that to just went down come back
poor guy whatever that means and so
after joe the next person up is
logically kamala the issue is that
kamala pulls five points worse than joe
i think that this particular story had
her approval rating at 28 or something
very low
and so
then the democrats find themselves in a
bit of a bind which is like okay if joe
doesn't run and joe will be 81 82 by the
time 2024 rolls around now kamala was
picked and this is the the tough thing
is that when joe picked kamala he
essentially did anoint her the future of
the democratic party the next president
yes
and we we all could see that very
clearly i mean joe's kind of on the
older side joe said he was going to be a
bridge so by appointing kamala he said
she is going to be the next president of
the united states there's one thing
that's always inherent in the vp pick
that sometimes they miss so they pick a
name that's going to help them win or
unite the party
but it also means showing the world this
person can be considered the future of
the party whether or not it's true or
not um anyway well there have been
different pics that have served
different functions at different times
so
like dan quayle back in the day george
bush no one thought that dude was going
to be president dick cheney with george
w
president no one thought he was going
but everybody thought he'd be running
the show even joe biden under uh under
barack obama obama chose him in part
because he would quote unquote be too
old to have his own political ambitions
afterwards and he checked the experience
box yes that was around the experience
so it's not always the case that the
next person up is going to be the next
president of the heir apparent but on
this one it was clear that kamala was
being positioned as the um the next one
up in the air apparent right and i'm
going to say something i've never said
to you privately or publicly okay but
when joe chose kamala i had a bit of a
sinking feeling because i was like oh
gosh we're going to position kamala to
be the next president and kamala even
then reminded me forcibly of hillary
clinton where she was a popular blue
state senator in california but
california is a very big state it's not
that much retail it was essentially like
a tv type tv can it raise the money you
usually win yes tv candidate uh raise
the money kamala wins
one of the reasons why kamala got out
when she did in the presidential was it
was before california voted and
i i'm genuinely not sure what her
support level or popularity is in
california
she ran a presidential campaign like
hillary that underperformed i mean
hillary came very very close to winning
whereas kamala did not and so you look
at it and you're like okay what has this
person done to warrant
them being the next president the united
states and you would have to say that it
was in large part because joe said very
publicly i'm going to have a woman vice
president no which is not a terrible
sentiment i think i said something
similar um but then after he announced
that he said
uh
he he i had a lot of pressure to name a
woman of color so then it quickly got
constrained to a few choices it was
kamala
uh
susan rice or karen bass were like the
three most prominent women of color that
seemed like realistic choices
and then kamala had been vetted of those
three and when you're running for
president
the key is just to try and win and so
kamala seemed like the safest pick
of the three of them
but even then when this was happening i
was like oh no this is going to be
hillary clinton redux when or if uh
kamala becomes the nominee um which is
what a lot of people are facing right
now they're looking at it and saying
kamal is clearly the next person up
kamala's clearly not connecting with
people she's not that popular and so
there is an agenda from some people
within the
uh the democratic administration either
because they want to boost another
candidate or because they they want to
blame some of the failings on kamala um
or maybe they simply don't like her as a
candidate are trying to find ways to to
get her out um but there is definitely
something going on where people are
trying to undermine and shiv her uh and
that there is a significant part of me
that understands it because i'm like
look if you just go in with kamala as
your nominee
it's not like a winning rationale or a
winning candidacy i mean like it and the
way democrats right now are going to
look at this is that every cycle is
existential uh and so you you know so
you you can't afford us to be like yeah
we're gonna run this person because
you know she's the beef she's up next
and she's nub next and she's a woman of
color and you know there are elements of
the party that would really really love
that um so i i did think all of this
uh back in in 2020 when this was
happening i was like wow if if this
ticket wins then there's going to be a
hillary slash kamala problem um the next
cycle
in some ways it would have been better
to bring in someone who didn't have that
kind of profile or independent political
ambition in my opinion but
on the other hand can't fault joe
because it was the safest pick to win
and he won yup um and hindsight the
right decision at the time right um but
now we're well the other piece of this
too is that is that some people some
commentators have said something which i
don't think is wrong they were like like
shocker their teams aren't meshing um
and one of the things that did happen is
that kamala's team
um
kind of came apart during the
presidential and then when they
installed her as vice president they
installed new people around her so
unlike most folks who reach that level
where you have the a bunch of hardened
operatives who've been trusted thick and
thin who care about it like it'd be like
if if i was let's say i was vice
president right now you know there'd be
zach there'd be a handful of other
people that uh that we'd been through
some wars together so at least we have
that dynamic in kamala's case
uh like it's a different group of people
uh it's like professionals some people
are connected to biden world and so she
doesn't have this core
uh group and to the extent they're
bringing in new people they're people
that she has to establish trust and
chemistry with by the way when you're in
a position where it's very very hard to
develop trust me because so because you
would look around and think like hey
this person has their own agenda which
just but all of them do like all the
people around commonwealth have an
agenda independent of kamala yep we live
this because you have to hire people on
the fly and there's only a certain
people you trust in there but they those
people you trust don't always have the
experience and the job is changing right
like you may have someone you worked for
for 30 years but now you've got an
immigration challenge you've been tasked
to do like the border wall xyz you don't
know anybody you trust
as an expert on the border right you
have to find them and that is very very
hard so i did there was a part in the
article they talked about her leaning on
her i think brother-in-law and uh sister
and other others in the family but to me
i think that's bs i think that if you're
in a role there's only a few people you
can actually trust who are on team comma
no matter what and you have to at least
like you always give them an ear if you
will um and they can they can be
downfall that there's downsides that but
um there's less downside with someone
who's an independent thinker frankly
which she
given her political career doesn't
always have the opportunity to be at
times
that was not my point here's my thought
i've said this to you guys when you read
an article when you hear numbers that
are a little vague you need to call red
flag so this was a direct quote from the
article it said nearly three dozen they
interviewed nearly three dozen
former and current harris aides
administration officials democratic
operatives donors and outside advisors
who spoke extensively to cnn
so yes three dozen is a closer that's
not numerous or multiple which i always
flag
but i don't know is that one or two
staffers and a whole bunch of donors and
outside like there's the waiting there
seems off to me um i mean she has a
gajillion donors yeah that could be that
could be a whole bunch of things um so
that's what's interesting to your point
like when you said
someone has it out for or someone's
trying to shiver like that makes sense
and if you say yeah we did 36 interviews
but we don't know how many internal aids
are talking and how many people actually
know what they're talking about talking
not really and none of them are publicly
on record the people that are public on
record generally speaking are very
removed from the white house
and talking positive
there's a couple people negative but all
of them the people on record in this
piece
are talking from outside of the white
house so you got the lieutenant governor
of california you have some democratic
operatives around the country
uh so i to me it's like
you know is it that much a disaster in
there i think it comes down to your
point like the core of the political
dynamics here like she was picked as the
future of the party when she
didn't have necessarily the populist or
popular support
that would kind of anoint that you know
yes so that that so
there is a passage in the article where
they say maybe they'll appoint her to
the supreme court to like you know give
her a place to go very yeah the cards
move so that there is this really
uh
persistent strain where people are
looking up saying well we have to do
something
um and another part of this article is
saying that she's not going to scare off
the field um but then when they talk
about the field it's all people who i
ran with in 2020 booty judge yeah i'm
going to say something that you know i
don't think it's going to shock people
it's like i don't think the answer comes
from
um like some of the
also rans in the 2020 democratic field
you know i i it's
uh it's tough to see uh you know like
that there's like they
we all had issues and drawbacks
certainly electorally and politically in
in my opinion it's one reason why in an
earlier
email i suggested you know you need
someone new on that side uh i i believe
that still it's like uh that's one of
the problems
this is gonna be hard because for the
democrats to win
and and i mean win like they have to run
the right candidate and then that
candidate has to be appealing that
candidate has to get through the dem be
able to play the democrat i'm a democrat
team dem card
and they have to appeal to
frankly anti-establishment voters in the
middle
right where they're like
called independents
moderate right moderate left
um it's probably a number of voters that
decided the election in the state of
virginia right that's that type of voter
that's hard um
buddhist like maybe he has a lot of
trouble in in the states um where the
there's a large voter of women and
people of color particularly the black
vote um like south carolina was not
great for pete um
that'll be hard for him
other than that man i don't know like
tulsi gabbard theoretically would do
well but i you know there's democrats
the democrats never let her go in you
know i'm thinking about like people that
could actually maybe do it
um and the dems will never let tulsi in
um you're out so the democratic party i
don't know who they got i really don't
we gotta think about it
[Music]
right now the most likely candidates are
joe and kamala um it's going to be one
of those two and joe is saying publicly
and privately that he's going to run
again when i talk to folks in you know
or in ordinary day-to-day conversation
people are like people groan a bit
because
you know we can tell he's getting on in
years i mean he will be 81-82 by the
time the next election rolls around uh i
i'll say someone said to me privately uh
i mean i won't you know out this person
but someone was around someone who
attended the uh g20 yeah conference
recently who was around just the photos
were so awkward but then they
but then this person was very negative
about joe running again in part because
of like whatever vibe he gave off oh boy
um there were i don't know there's truth
to these but a lot of conservative
outlets were said he farted in front of
a leader
breaking wind was the well that one
certainly doesn't upset anyone i mean
that that's people farts you know uh i
think it's funny um
the
i mean i bet trump farted
sure he farted uh
you look at donald trump that dude farts
that dude farts trump plus he eats
mcdonald's all the live long day or
whatever dude that's intentional has got
to be a wreck digestive tract gotta be
absolutely yeah
he's like a big dude yeah fast food all
the time i don't judge people for that
yeah plus he also doesn't seem like the
type who would be restraining his
splatulence until he's like no i just
let him rip man yeah like he's like i'm
president of the united states
doing whatever i want yeah i teach their
own i can't believe this turned into
parts do you think
do you think comma is uh
do you think she's set up to fail you
know uh
like yeah i feel like she's like
everything's hard all the institutions
are busted whatever she's throwing is
this is the thing that does stagger me
about this whole thing zach is that you
bring in kamala
and a lot of it should be
that she becomes the media darling
and that's why this piece was so
significant in my mind is that she's
somehow the opposite of the media
darling yeah she's like the media
punching bag
and if if you have someone who has that
relationship with the media right now
when frankly
so you could say hey look it's three
years away or two and a half years away
like all these things can change blah
blah blah like uh you know this should
be the honeymoon that's really my point
i mean like this should be the point
where it's kind of harder to do wrong
and so when you talk about is she being
set up to fail i mean she had a tough
assignment with the border
uh you know i mean it is a very
important issue to a lot of americans uh
you know the the problem is that the
official administration stance and what
kamala i think is being asked to say and
do doesn't line up with the
uh
inclination of the democratic base yeah
so if you're saying look this is a
shitty assignment it's like well it's a
shitty assignment if your job is to
curry favor with a democratic base that
by the way is going to play an outside
role in the next primary
um one of the the interesting things
about this really is that at least in my
mind there is not going to be a
democratic primary joe's going to run
again no one challenges them except for
actually no one challenges them really
and then that's that like that that's
what i see is the most likely scenario
gosh and now if it's kamala apparently
people challenge like that i guess that
that was really the point of this piece
is that like combo's not going to clear
the field was that that would be my
summary of this piece in cnn kamala will
not clear the field which is another
reason in my mind why it's going to be
joe
well if she's going to run as vp she
needs a signature win or something and
that's kind of the point i think she's
kind of set up to fail like if they're
going to throw the border at her which
it's hard for anybody and gems don't
talk about the border well you go down
the list right um so
we'll see i i honestly i felt bad for
her i think um and anyone can write a
staff piece on you it's um this was you
know well done yeah you you have dozens
and dozens of staffers you get like
someone that's one of the issues with
today is that like if you want to write
a hit piece on someone you can get
someone who worked for that person to
trash them easy because it's like you
know dozens of people you know if you
imagine someone had like 100 staffers
how many of those 100 staffers are
not awesome people you know like let's
say
they're like 10 people with an axe to
grind and then a reporter sticks a mic
in their face and it's like hey what do
you want to say and then you know it's
like so so that that's one of the
uh
atmospheric elements right now that just
makes me uncomfortable really is like
i'm reading all these pieces where
someone's just like getting trashed and
you're just like oh my gosh like uh you
know and then there are words that get
thrown in there too and that that make
it seem super serious so seriously
there's part of me that's like you know
what it's not against the law to be an
you know what i mean like and
then in certain contexts it's just like
you know this person like acted like an
that time and then you're like
didn't invite me to xyz company out
later maybe using karaoke or so you know
whatever it happens to be i mean
certainly oh i've had more versions of
that it the 80 20 rule is what i said
like we hired it was like 200 plus
people in a month on the presidential
campaign like of those 200 people
if we hit on 80 of them i'd call that a
grand slam that would be wonderful
pretty excellent right that means you're
a very good hirer
and that fast too but so that means like
40 of those you missed which either
means you have to work around them or
let them go and all those situations are
awful especially on a campaign when
things are moving and so that you know
of those 40 people or some upset like
yeah and it's it's tough um but that
doesn't mean they're great people either
and you know there's plenty you know but
the
160 or so you got right who aren't
talking to press they're left out of the
piece right that's uh that's always well
because that's a non-story yeah
everyone's like hey kyle's doing great
you know like uh you know i loved
working there
yeah and look to me this is like part of
being in the arena right you wanna get
in the arena this is the you deal
with fine but uh
readers should also know like the whole
story too make their own judgment
um
yes anyway the the summary of the story
for me was someone wants to run against
kamala oh yeah um
i'm curious we're gonna see we're gonna
know who here's the other thing like the
difference between now in 2024 it's
gonna be a whole different ball game you
know again i think that's why it's joe i
think democrats want to avoid this
speaking of dems some more let's talk
about beto beto o'rourke announced he's
running for governor of texas
our friend beto o'rourke
um
let me say upfront yeah go ahead uh i am
friends with beto he's a very good dude
nice guy we are about the same age
so we bonded uh as fellow gen xers uh on
the trail
um you know i i uh we've helped each
other out a little bit he sent me some
uh salsa after i did something nice for
daddy yeah yeah was it good salsa yeah
it was delicious like texas el paso
badass salsa yeah that's good stuff sure
yeah nice um
so i like betto i think he's a good man
yeah all right continue well
so i'll start with let's say
i watched his announcement video was
nicely done in the sense of just him
shooting to a camera which i always
like one take
so perhaps you better
basically the take i got was uh
government doesn't work for people and
like the texas like uh
electric grid crisis was a wake-up call
to him which to be fair is you know it's
tough to find a good why you're running
um if you've been a politician your
whole life um which he has essentially
besides a brief stint as a rocker for a
bit
uh
but i think that's solid um
so i have a ton of thoughts but i
definitely want yours unless you want me
to dive in um no i'm happy to go for a
better work running for government what
do you think yeah so the current
governor seems
like
governor abbott yeah governor abbott has
problems
uh he does have some approval problems
like some people are eager to move on
i think it's going to be a tough
atmosphere for democrats
there is you know in some ways it's just
easier to run against whoever's in
office because people just get ticked
off at who's in office and in this case
it's the the republican uh but i do
think it's gonna be a tough climate for
democrats i can see why beto is running
in part because he is the most prominent
democrat in texas the other prominent
democrats did not want to take this
particular race on
uh and one of the things that bedo is
determined to do is just try and help
turn texas blue over time so win or lose
is better going to be a more energizing
candidate than just about anyone else
that they could muster 100 yes you know
like the
the extent that there were other
democratic
stars really there aren't that many but
also it didn't seem like they wanted
this one so i think that beto is running
because he thinks that he can help
democrats statewide and relatively
speaking that is true
um i think it's going to be a tough
climate though for dems um
next year
uh and it's going to be an uphill battle
in my opinion some of the things that
bitto said on the presidential trail
are
not
in line with what i think a lot of texan
voters
want uh and you know like that in some
ways
you know you gotta
applaud beto for taking stands on stuff
he believed in right um but i i think
it's gonna be a really tough
tough road for him
[Music]
so abbott's approval ratings have
dropped
pretty significantly
um
44 approval rating of his work as
governor 47 disapproval rating
now i i don't know we've talked a lot in
this podcast about polls particularly in
the republican party um they tend to be
really wrong um
um but who knows um it's probably some
sort of drop particularly after the
abortion law so here's my thought i'm
split and i think we should be split
here on one hand if you ask my opinion
like on you andrew like if i was looking
at you like running like you run twice
you don't win either time
i think it's probably better to like
pause have a cool period yeah like cool
off for a bit um and i don't mean sale a
public eye that means that's a run um
so
he didn't run for house in 2018 after he
left that role when he was running for
senate lost senate ran for president
lost present um
had some moments there like i was born
to be in it or hell yes we're going to
take all your guns being from texas so i
don't love this on one hand oh my god
this is kind of
better running again right on the other
hand
i do think it's a good thing for
like the dem bench isn't that deep
and i do think it's good for bigger
democratic names to run for tough seats
that matter in the country it's one of
the biggest states yeah i think that's
the rationale i mean his uh his work has
been around just turning texas blue
there are a lot of democratic officials
in texas that would not have won their
races if not for better over this last
year so it's kind of tough imagine if
you're him and you're essentially
like the
person who can generate energy so
governor abbott has something like 50
million dollars or something like it
very very hard for a texas democrat to
compete with that and beto is i think
maybe the only person who could could
raise the money yeah it could raise
money don't get national damn support
big time yeah to be credible so it's
it's just a lot of responsibilities
looking around all the texts all the
texas democrats are begging him to run
too because they know some of what i
just said they know that he's the
biggest potential energizer
um so i i think that is the dynamic of
what's going on
um
yeah i mean i i'm uh i do like beto i i
think he's again like a
good man and you know wants to help
people yeah applaud anyone going in the
arena here's them to me the big ques
well actually and we should build on
something you said and i actually
referenced it a little bit earlier
what does the democratic bench look like
uh you know and and you saw it
essentially poured out for all to see
during the 2020
campaign it's like anyone who really had
that level of aspiration was in the
field with me
and beto and corey and you know tulsi
and whoever else it's like if you
thought you had it some people a lot of
folks here forget ran like seth moulton
you probably forget he ran um steve
bullock jonathan lipper yeah
um you forget they ran some of them are
you know like thriving in aok like john
hagen looper is now in the senate
but
there's there's something going on in
american life
particularly on the democratic side
where we are not developing or breeding
leaders
the next generation to the extent that
there are people that come up they're
almost embodiments of
like a certain type of social media
argument uh and that they command like a
niche following
um but
they don't really have
uh like national potential
that there's something really a foot
it's tough it's really bad and but this
isn't even just in democratic politics
i'm going to say that america right now
is suffering from something of a
leadership vacuum
uh and uh it's in part because the
market dynamics are so strong now that
we're all subject to them and if you go
against them which by the way in my
opinion is a little bit of what
leadership looks like it's like if the
market's gonna reward you for doing
something you do it and everyone kind of
on some level senses that that's what's
going on that's what's fueling you and
so then we look around and there's no
one who can actually
lay claim
to
a broad type of moral authority or
popularity the closest thing we can come
to it nowadays
is celebrity
um you know and so you had i talked to
someone the other day who said something
you know you can agree or disagree but
you know barack obama was a celebrity of
certain kind you have political
celebrities of certain kinds and this is
one reason why they're kind of old like
hillary and joe and bernie
and this person said at this point and
then donald trump's the most obvious
example he's just like a flat out
capital c celebrity who became president
and so his argument was at this point
it's going to be celebrities um because
no one gives a about like the
random public official from xyz and then
the media now has become less
powerful and adept at elevating that
person to the stratosphere like obama
got the stratospheric elevation
treatment he gave the
um the uh
speech at the dnc convention everyone
was like wow and the media was like wow
and then everyone was like oh check this
guy out he's going to the rest of it
and it's been interesting trying to
watch them do the same thing
every cycle since then that was 04 they
tried to know 8 12 16. i don't know
about you all but i don't even remember
who gave those speeches in
8 12 16. obama where the party is going
to try and anoint and elevate this
person and then they say hey media take
it from here but it just has not been
happening
i'm writing about this right now um i
got a book coming may but the concept of
i call it instead of a brand identity
where it's like we're cool brandon he's
like we're coke cola here's our colors
red and white santa claus polar bears
it's identity branding where people
identify with the candidate um and it's
that
it it creates that sort of
well one it's identifying with them as a
human and a personal level but then it
creates that kind of like die hard fan
base and stickiness with the candidate
and
the challenge with that is it
fosters like niche uh
type issues and candidates right so you
become
whether it's medicare for all or your
universal basic income people identify
with you the human and what you're
fighting for but it ends up creating
these kind of brands for the moment in a
way where
in a cash relief race you're great but
the race stiff's a crime and that's not
that's not the right candidate right you
end up with people who are when the race
is about medicare for all they have a
certain lame but if it's about
compromising in dc around health care
it's less so right over shift to
something else um
and that was actually my point in this
the big question i think in this beto
race is probably
what the message ends up being what he
has because if he can run on the
abortion law which is deeply unpopular
even with republicans and becomes a
champion for women in that in texas like
you're going to get a ton of national
money in there you probably have a shot
if it becomes on
if it sticks to like guns or
critical race theory or whatever what
happened virginia like i don't know um
and this is maybe to your point like why
it's tougher to build a bench because
you end up within
like a aoc or on omar which where
they're
very popular in certain areas but it's
in that lane and they don't have as much
broad national appeal i mean you're
winning a whole state in texas you've
got to be a little more
i'd like to say like bud light marketing
over like sweetwater hail or some like
unique type you know you have to be more
palatable to the average i think i don't
know what you're thinking that but
that's oh no i so so if so if you're
like a social scientist or a political
taxonomist you regard america as
generally like a centrist or a slightly
right of center leaning population
and then the the people that have become
really um
popular on the the left uh have very
strong appeal with a subset of americans
and that's how you become prominent in
certain circles it's called media or
social media but then it's going to be
tough to translate that
um more broadly that said now there are
you know frankly legions of people that
would still want for
that success within that niche you know
what i mean uh so but but it is one of
those things where it's going to make it
harder not easier to breed someone who
actually has a high level of crossover
appeal
we would joke about this on the campaign
too there's a difference between
and this gets overused at times but
there's difference between irl and url
you know where it's url on the website
uh
you get a lot of tweets and all likes
and even donations and like lots of
millions of views on your podcast or
youtube show but then in real life like
that doesn't actually translate to
people actually vote in a democratic
primary or republican primary um
so
the the media is a big part of this too
if you come out in a certain way then
they'll be like okay you're the modern
in this race you're the moderator yeah
they'll find your lane for you yeah they
just try and find that ideological lane
and then um and then they'll be like do
you think your moderate message fits
with these
like uh you know liberals on the left
that represent like the energy in the
future the part like that's the way
they'll frame things and so they'll try
and like slice and dice and segment
to a point where again it's very
difficult for someone to develop
a broader appeal that's going to cross
over even within let's say the
democratic party much less uh to to
other voters
god bless beto for one doing this i
guess and but mainly he's got to run for
a year
that's going to suck
he's got to put some more miles on on
the truck that's a lot cause because
he's he he's a driver he like drives all
over texas when he does this thing he's
he works hard
one thing i'll say too about betto is
the man runs he grinds yeah like but he
you know he's like a runner
um
but he runs like someone who runs let's
put it that way yeah he's running like
half marathon stuff right yeah he does
like he he his campaigns are you know
like marathons like endurance feats yeah
you know it it's fun talking about folks
that we literally ran with and against
uh people that we've gotten to know it
does give you a different perspective
if you want to get to know people who
run for president run for president
because it turns out that you end up
being around them um but the the way
that these folks are in real life and
the way that you
interact within the media sometimes i
gotta say they are somewhat different i
i you know i'm not sure if i resemble
that too
um but it's it's fascinating to see what
people who are
on the trail with us end up doing as
their next act you know and and you know
i i i can relate to aspects of it i mean
like i'm doing what i think i
uh can do to have the most positive
impact possible and i think that's
something that different people actually
experience after they come off running
for president when
we do meetings or so we're doing a whole
bunch of different projects when i have
meetings with people who never met you
before but knew of you or fans of yours
the number one thing i always hear
andrew is like wow he's just like he is
when he's on tv it's the exact same guy
and i my response every time is a yep
exactly um for better or for worse it's
him andrew yang shitty politician hey
man because you know because i'm the
same dude it's true i mean you know i
mean yeah
this is like
a politician it's like you'd be like bad
you're like bad because you know you're
you're a lousy liar to your credit
you've never claimed to be a good
politician oh well thank you yeah we
claim to be good marketers and i think
we are generally speaking uh you know i
i mean uh like you have to say
objectively i've been a very good
politician because you know i made a
dent in the presidential years and like
out competed like a dozen you know like
brand names thank you yang gang thank
you forward community
uh for being here for us but we you know
we're just gonna continue to make
history you know things are going to
take different forms something evelyn
said to me that she appreciated she said
you know like i'm so glad that you're
continuing to evolve and grow and
develop and it's not like the the same
stuff
in part because you know i'm a human
being and like i see things and see the
problems i have a different sense of
what we can do to help at a at any given
time and in part because we get bored we
need to do new you know well we
have a lot of new coming down the
plane again so if if you're into what's
going on those last uh couple months
like you haven't seen anything yet you
ain't seen nothing yet that's our show
love you guys
see you on monday
[Music]
you